mit 20 kein sozialist ist hat kein herz
wäre es mit 40 immer noch ist hat keinen
verstand
das sagte winston churchill der mann der
heute bei mir zu gast ist über 40 und er
verteidigt die idee des sozialismus
er hat aber definitiv auch eine menge
verstand bei mir sitzt nämlich heute
axel honneth einer der wichtigsten
philosophen deutschlands er leitet das
legendäre institut für sozialforschung
in frankfurt an dem horkheimer und
adorno und später auch habermas
philosophie geschichte schrieben
axel honneth meint wir sollten der sache
des sozialismus nochmals eine chance
geben
ich bin gespannt wie weit wir heute
damit kommen herzlich willkommen axel
honneth sie verteidigen in ihrem
neuesten buch die idee des sozialismus
eine totgesagte idee sind sie stur oder
mutig auch das will ich gar nicht so
beurteilen irgendwo steckt auch
sicherlich ein stück sturheit drin ja
auch der versuch mir klar zu werden
warum ich immer wie selbstverständlich
wenn man mich gefragt hätte welche
politischen überzeugung ich eigentlich
habe ich glaube seit 40 jahren seitdem
ich irgendwie überhaupt politisch
kratzen worden bin mit 20 gesagt hätte
ich bin sozialist ohne dass ich mir
große gedanken darüber gemacht hätte wie
ich den begriffen und fülle
das heißt dieser begriff wurde diese
selbstbezeichnung hat die ganzen auf und
ab der letzten politischen jahrzehnte
überstanden und in irgendeiner stelle
sein mittels seines lebens kommt man
dann in das alter sich zu fragen was
meinst du eigentlich damit das war
sicherlich einer der anlässe er so ein
biografischer an dass sich das buch so
zurecht zu legen
ein anderer bestand darin darüber rede
ich dann ja auch in der einleitung dass
man sich klarmachen muss diese diese
idee des sozialismus hat ich würde man
sagen 100
40 jahre lang die herzen große mengen
von menschen bewegt der großer
bevölkerungsteile bewegt und jetzt soll
er plötzlich verschwunden sein ich weiß
nicht genau seit wann wahrscheinlich
würde man im rückblick heute sagen oder
intellektuelle würden sagen oder
journalisten würden sagen seit 1989 dass
pfarrer maurer ja fall der mauer und ich
finde dass wir die idee zu schnell
verabschieden wenn wir so damit umgehen
schauen wir mal wie sie wieder aus der
taufe heben können
nun ist es ja so dass die idee nicht nur
realpolitisch nicht wirklich
funktioniert hat sondern sie hat auch zu
ganz grausam erschienen geführt also
denken wir an mauro in china denken wir
an den gulag müsste man nicht auch sagen
die idee ist einfach an sich zu
gefährlich na gut das ich versuche in
dem buch ist mir klarzumachen warum die
warum eine idee die in den anfängen
denk ich noch nicht gefährlich war
warum sie dann im laufe ihrer
verwirklichung tatsächlich auch solche
politischen antidemokratischen exzesse
hat hervorrufen können das muss man sich
klar machen ich glaube wenn man heute
irgendwie den versuch unternehmen möchte
die idee des sozialismus noch einmal
irgendwo irgendwie zu retten
dann sollte man sich um die frage nicht
drücken
und wenn ich die nicht so direkt
anspreche ja das steht uns natürlich
allen vor augen und sicherlich gerade
denen die heute mit dem sozialismus gar
nichts mehr anzufangen wissen dass in
seinem namen auch diese verbrechen an
der menschheit begangen
also kann man ich will nur sagen das
muss man mit bedenken und man muss
irgendwie sich über die ursachen
möglicherweise auch in dem in dem
konzept selber rechenschaft ablegen das
ist richtig sie sagen man muss schauen
sich rechenschaft ablegen sie würden
also nicht so weit gehen wie der
britische literaturwissenschaftler terry
eagleton der ein marxist und der sagt
wenn man marx für mario verantwortlich
macht nichts
dasselbe wie man jesus für die
inquisition verantwortlich macht
so weit würde ich nicht gehen ich glaube
man muss schon auch sich sehr ernsthaft
die frage vorlegen ob es etwa im werk
wurzeln gibt oder anhaltspunkte gibt die
die nachträgliche verfremdung der idee
und politischen den politischen
missbrauch die idee mit haben
verursachen können also das ist mir
schwer gefallen die die die grundidee
wie ich sie herauszuarbeiten versuche
ist sicherlich noch war jeder solchen
möglichkeiten der politischen
zweckentfremdung aber wie die idee
eingehüllt wird in welche lenksysteme in
welcher vorstellungswelten sieht schon
damals auch zu marktzeiten eingeholt
wurde
das gibt er anders denke ich zum
nachdenken und auch zur überprüfung der
frage ob nicht vielleicht die wurzeln
auch der zweckentfremdung will dort zu
suchen sind in der frühe und zwar zu
suchen sollten also bin ich ganz der
meinung wenn wir den anlass des buches
sei uns anschauen schreiben sie in
diesem buch das sie eigentlich motiviert
waren dem sozialismus noch mal auf die
schliche zu kommen
als sie sozusagen festgestellt haben
dass unsere gesellschaft von einem
tiefen zwiespalt zerrissen die hat auf
der einen seite gibt es eine bereits
geteilte unzufriedenheit mit den
sozioökonomischen zuständen in unserer
welt wie wir sind unglücklich darüber
wie das kapital beispielsweise verteilt
ist die ungerechte welt ist und auf der
anderen seite sagen sie dieser unmut ist
seltsam richtungslos richtig das halte
ich auch weiterhin für eine richtige
diagnose die besagt noch nicht allzu
viel hat sie besagt nur dass sagen wir
mal seit dem beginn all das muss man so
die neoliberalen entgrenzung des
kapitalismus nennt ja 1980 er jahre
achtziger jahre
mitte der 80er jahre mit all den
erscheinungen die das hervorgebracht hat
und die weiterhin ein bisschen
überraschend sind wenn man sich die
zeiten davor anguckt in denen der
kapitalismus irgendwie auf dem weg der
einigung und der sozialstaatlichen china
haben wir ja seither phänomene die
erstaunlich sind und die glaube ich und
denke ich mir schon viele menschen
empören
ja das fängt an bei diesen gehältern für
manager deren höhe wir uns deswegen
nicht merken können weil sie so absurd
es ja bis hin zur deregulierung des
arbeitsmarktes zu erlaubnis von
finanzspekulationen für die dem licht
ökonomen auch nur das verständnis fehlt
ja dass die neuerscheinungen muss man
sich klar machen
das gab es vorher in dem maße nicht zum
beispiel diese finanzpakete diese
finanzspekulation gab es nicht und die
empörung darüber da bin ich mir sicher
hat zugenommen es gibt mehr und mehr
menschen denke ich die sich fragen ob
das die richtige form
die richtige wirtschaftsminister und auf
der anderen seite aber denke ich hat man
ich auch eigentlich keine konkrete
vorstellungen an der alternative die
vorstellungen die es über alternativen
gab sind verbraucht haben sich blamiert
ja die plan planwirtschaft
zentralisierte planwirtschaft wissen wir
alle
funktioniert nicht bei komplexen
ökonomien wie wir sie haben auch die
anderen ideen scheint alle die dies da
vielleicht gibt's schon mal viel zu
kleinteilig zu touristisch genau man hat
irgendwie bedingungsloses grundeinkommen
oder nun wachstum ja allen ideen hat man
auch ein bisschen den eindruck oft man
versteht einen nicht gar nicht so recht
wie das sozusagen das pflaster sein
sondern für die wunde auf die ihr habt
ja ja ist vollkommen richtig und das
sind vielleicht bausteine also
bedingungsloses grundeinkommen ist ja
eine attraktive idee über die man auch
wer sich unterhalten könnte aber so die
vision eine alternative fehlt und das
ist glaube ich der grund dass dieser
dieses unbehagen auf der einen seite die
sich kaum in einem protest ja es gab
natürlich die occupy-bewegung die aber
alles in allem auch nicht sehr
erfolgreich sondern muss man sagen ja
und schon wieder eher im verschwinden
begriffen ist also ist dieses unbehagen
richtungslos artikulation es los und
bleibt insofern ohne politische
repräsentanz mit sicherheit ja ich meine
man muss sich klar machen dass die
arbeiter bewegung eine massenbewegung
dass das nimmt natürlich nach dem ende
des zweiten weltkriegs nicht mehr exakt
dieselben großen formen an wie in der
republik etwa ob in den ländern
frankreich die arbeit der begehung war
eine eine massenbewegung die die gemüter
auch der konservativen intellektuellen
unterbrochen beschäftigt hat und
insofern da ist anders man hatte ja
vorstellungen utopische vorstellungen
sich sicherlich klassenlose gesellschaft
einer ganz anderen ökonomie
das fanden auch die unterstützung von
großen teilen der arbeiterschaft also es
war das jetzt bevor wir sozusagen über
die therapie dieser schwierigkeiten
sprechen die sie eben von dem sie denken
und könnte vielleicht in der idee des
sozialismus etwas finden was
therapeutikum dienen könnte sprechen
jedoch nochmals kurz über die sagen
nehmer krankheiten unserer zeit
sie haben schon angetönt diese
unzufriedenheit geben aber auch so ein
bisschen unklar ist was was ist das
sammelbecken dessen was uns freiheit
führt was würden sie denn sagen was ihn
wirklich die einzelnen bausteine der
problematik gegenwärtig da gibt es
sicherlich vieles aber der kern nicht
wahrscheinlich in einem vorkommen trends
markt der in andere lebensbereiche im
stärker masse an trägt als
wahrscheinlich
in den dreißig vierzig jahren nach dem
ende des zweiten weltkriegs
das heißt die ökonomisierung weiter
bereiche unseres sozialen lebens die
krassen ungleichheiten die durch den
markt wie im augenblick reguliert ist
oder die reguliert ist der verbracht
werden ja die obszöne ausmaße annehmen
das weiß man eigentlich viel genauer
noch seit der seit diesem erfolgreichen
buch von peter t überhaupt hat man das
gefühl da ist etwas uns den bürgerinnen
und bürgern vollkommen aus dem ruder
gelaufen wir haben keinen zugriff mehr
auf dieses ökonomische system selbst die
politische regierung scheint abhängig zu
sein vom diktat der großen banken und
man könnte jetzt natürlich im einzelnen
die ganzen phänomene durchgehend ja wie
gesagt das fängt an glaube ich bei der
zunehmenden verarmung öffentlicher güter
man muss nur durch unsere großstädte
gehen vergleicht das immer als ich 20
war und im ruhrgebiet groß geworden
wegen gab es florierende badeanstalten
ja und zwar in jedem stadtteil reinen
die gut in schuss waren und die von uns
jugendlichen auch massiv genutzt wurden
heute sind schwimmbäder entweder marode
oder sind privatisiert worden und
deswegen wesentlich teurer geworden als
der damaligen zeit und das ist nur ein
kleiner ausschnitt
denken sie an ich weiß nicht wieder sind
der schweiz sind und das sagen ich
glaube das problem mit den schwimmbädern
machen zum beispiel wohnungsmarkt des
wohnungsmarktes wohnungsmarkt spiel
diesen profitieren von quartieren
entwickelt dann kann man nicht mehr
leben
ein und der eines der ganz großen
probleme der westdeutschen großstädten
der deutschen großstädte ist dass
wohnraum für auch nur mittelständische
familien mit mittlerem einkommen kaum
mehr in angemessener im angemessenen
ausmaß zur verfügung steht
erschwinglicher wohnraum
man kann das nur vergleichen immer mit
wien wo der wohnungsmarkt sozial und
politisch wesentlich stärker
kontrolliert ist und die schwierigkeiten
viel geringer sind
das stammt aus einer zeit im übrigen als
der sozialismus noch eine lebendige idee
war und kein skandal wie er heute
manchmal zu sein scheint ja damals hat
der wiener wohnungsbau ganz
fortschrittlich daran gearbeitet guten
soliden wohnraum für die masse der
bevölkerung zur verfügung zu stellen das
hat sich erhalten
und wenn man das vergleicht mit
frankfurt münchen hamburg berlin ist der
kontrast augen öffnet ich denke ich mir
noch einmal vor augen was am anfang
gesagt haben haben sie gesagt es geht es
um diese durch ökonomisierung aller
lebensbereiche das ist etwas was man
immer wieder diskutiert sind in ihrem
buch auch einen verweis auf eva illouz
die soziologin die betont wie
beispielsweise auch die
liebesbeziehungen von der ökonomie
ergriffen werden die es keinen unsere
partner dauernd auf die frage hin ob es
gleich noch jemand besseren gäbe und mit
kinder können wir die perfekte person
unserer umgebung finden um uns zu
treffen das stimmt wahrscheinlich alles
ich habe immer das gefühl viele leute
beschäftigt das vielleicht gar nicht so
sehr sondern dass ich so eine meta-ebene
philosophen und soziologen sprechen
darüber sondern etwas was ich glaube was
viele leute auch beschäftigt ist diese
frage leben wir nicht über quasi unseren
ressourcen ist es nicht so dass hier ich
weiß nicht wie viele wälzen bräuchten um
in zukunft überhaupt noch existieren zu
können also stichwort klimawandel
der ganze verbrauch der ressourcen ist
das etwas was sie auch beschäftigt in
diesem zusammenhang natürlich das gehört
wahrscheinlich dazu lasse mich noch
einen schritt zurückgehen
ich will dieses biete ökonomisierung
aller lebensbereiche gar nicht
übertreiben ich bin da auch skeptischer
als erstes zum beispiel ich glaube es
gibt
die weiterhin robust genug sind und die
auch in unser aller augen schützenswert
sind und in die wir und in die hinein zu
lassen ökonomische prinzipien und
maßstäbe erfolgs gesichtspunkte wir sehr
vorsichtig sind ich bin da ein bisschen
optimistischer ich habe im wesentlichen
vor augen die öffentlichen güter schulen
krankenhäuser die zunehmend
universitäten auch unter einem
ökonomischen erfolgs druck geraten der
ihnen nicht gut tut und ihre
ursprünglichen funktion glaube ich sehr
massiv widersprechen
das ist der kern bereich in dem ich
diese ökonomisierung vorn schreiten sie
ein anderer ausdruck davon
der aber gewissermaßen er mit dem
kapitalistischen industrie als solchen
zu tun hat und vielleicht gar nicht so
sehr mit diesen neoliberalen entgrenzung
der letzten jahrzehnte ist das ja das
wagt der wachs des wachstums im
imperativ der uns dazu anhält immer
exzessiver zu produzieren und eigentlich
maßnahmen der einsparung nur schwer
ertragen zu können
das ist ein problem was sich
möglicherweise viel weniger durch
regulierungen natürlich auch durch
regulierung lösen lässt aber vielleicht
am ende auch durch durch so etwas wie
kulturelles lernen um orientieren ja da
müssen wir ganz andere form des
wirtschaftens erst wieder werden sie
lieben die hälfte ihrer zeit in new york
wo sie auch eine professur haben und der
columbia university und man kann ja
sagen new york ist gleich so eines der
epizentren des kapitalismus mit der wall
street ist es so dass sie in new york
anders über den sozialismus nachzudenken
begonnen haben nie vorher sag mal so in
new york darüber nachzudenken ist
schwieriger als in frankfurt
nicht weil diese städte sich was zu
sagen wir die sichtbarkeit von
finanzeinrichtungen und danken anbelangt
so massiv unterscheiden da ist frankfurt
relativ nahe
dort würde ich mal sagen und anders
wiederum als vielleicht andere
großstädte sondern weil in den usa ja
interessant interessanterweise die idee
des sozialismus nie richtig fuß gefasst
hat einer der großen unterschied hat
schon max weber beobachtet und große
andere soziologen und historiker der
sozialismus ist eigentlich eine eine
europäische idee und aus gründen über
die man lange reden müsste hat sie in
den usa nie fuß gefasst hat die massen
nicht in demselben maße erregt und
begeistert wie in den verschiedenen
ländern europas
deswegen ist es in den usa anders ja es
ist ja nicht so
naja es gibt jetzt bei den demokraten
leute auch präsidentschaftskandidaten
die sich als sozialisten bezeichnen und
augen fern des senders ist einer dieser
repräsentanten ja aber die idee ist
sagen wir mal so die die iss mich
wirklich eingesickert in die kultur das
ist anders als hier
hier weiß jeder was sozialismus
irgendwie open und schlecht oder gut
bedeuten soll
das hat eine riesen tradition es hat
bewegung gegeben massive große bewegung
in den usa gab es eine kleine
kommunistische partei die schnell
verfolgt wurde in den zeiten der cassis
aber es ist nicht so dass es eine
massenbewegung je gewesen wäre und das
macht einen großen unterschied
sprechen wir über ihre idee bevor ich
aber los muss ich sie unbedingt noch
etwas fragen nämlich die widmung in
diesem buch hier steht meinen söhnen
johannes und rückwärts sie von anfang an
alles leichter gemacht haben
das möchte man natürlich wissen gemacht
dann könnte ich lange und zunächst klar
werden dass man in so einer staunten
über die widmung weil sie das gefühl
hatten sie hätten alles schwerer gemacht
und das ist vielleicht auch das gefühl
dass kinder haben und das ist auch
leitungs bedürftige ich habe glaube ich
was ganz einfaches gemeint ich denke
sobald man vater oder mutter ist also
kinder hat werden bestimmte excelle
belastungen irgendwie
weggefegt hat durch die aufmerksamkeit
und das glück dass das zusammensein mit
kindern bedeuten kann also es wird
irgendwie leichter das war tatsächlich
mein eindruck von anfang an ja das leben
wird leichter weil man nicht mehr so mit
sich selbst konfrontiert ist somit den
eigenen essentiellen unwägbarkeiten
ängsten nöten sondern man wird man
könnte auch sagen die zentriert ja da
ist sind immer die kinder die die etwas
wollen die etwas verdienen auch ja und
ich glaube die meisten würden sagen aber
das schränkt deine freiheit einig würde
gerade sagen das erleichtert einen auch
es gibt eine leichtigkeit in leben die
für mich eine neue erfahrung war und ich
glaube das teilen viele man muss sich
nur mal wieder erst klammern dass es so
ist und ich jetzt mal ein schönes peter
jemand der nicht über die
doppelbelastung schimpft nein nein das
ist kein leid mit michael bolz hat aber
wie er sagte
aber schaut doch mal irgendwie ist doch
die existenz von kindern urlaub das
eingenommene erstmal eine einschränkung
freiheit ich meine meine intuition war
immer das ja dass das eher erweiterung
von freiheit sind und spezielle form von
freiheit darstellen und es irgendwie ein
vorteil unserer kultur zu sagen übrigens
der männlichen kultur auch sehr häufig
in dem augenblick wo du dich binde ist
geht dir deine freiheit verloren 1 ein
klassisches bild der männer kultur ja
und das wird dann auch zelebriert durch
initiationsriten ja morgen beginnt zu
die ehe und damit endet eine freiheit
das halte ich für ein tief sitzendes
verständnis unserer kultur
ja weil man sich nicht hinreichend klar
macht dass man neue freiheiten gewinnt
man verliert man verliert vielleicht
eine bestimmte form der
individualistischen verleiht
aber man gewinnt ganz andere verwenden
und so auch im oman mit kindern bis
jetzt haben sie für mich diese widmung
so wunderbar ausgetauscht das absolut
klar wird dass eigentlich die vision ins
zentrum dieses buches steuert das
zentrum dieses buches ist ja tatsächlich
der freiheitsbegriff und zwar die
sogenannte soziale freiheit die sie da
herausstreichen was ist soziale freiheit
der hornet
ich habe es gerade schon berührt und es
eigentlich zu wollen und direkt
anzusteuern
das hängt ein bisschen damit zu sagen
wie ich mir diese ursprungsidee des
sozialismus zurechtzulegen für suche
immer muss ich in die situation des
frühen oder der ersten hälfte des 19
jahrhunderts versetzen die frühen
sozialisten leben alle unter dem
massiven gravierenden eindruck der
französischen revolution und ihrer
normativen prinzipien ja die werden groß
damit für die ist das eine
selbstverständlichkeit dass eine neue
epoche der gesellschaft begonnen hat die
unter den direktiven von freiheit
gleichheit und brüderlichkeit steht und
machen schnell die erfahrung wie viele
oder massen von betroffenen auch dass
die versprechen damit geäußert werden
sich nicht wirklich für wirklich im lauf
der ersten jahrzehnte
ich glaube das ist die geburtsstunde des
sozialismus und ich glaube die früh
sozialist ein bisschen zu mag so mag
selber legen sich das was sie dann
erfahren wir natürlich an den verarmten
arbeitermassen erfahren so zurecht dass
sie sagen dieses dieses dreier paar von
normativen prinzipien lässt sich
deswegen nicht wirklich versöhnen und
realisieren weil das was unter freiheit
heute verstanden wird heute damals also
ja in den frühen 19 jahrhundert
eigentlich nur private egoismus meint
das ist auch den ausdruck den markt dann
verwendet auch den die früh sozialisten
interessanterweise genauso schon
verwenden freiheit ist eigentlich das
gegeneinander
ich setze meine freiheit gegen den
anderen auf dem markt durch und dadurch
wird systematisch verhindert und ist
undenkbar dass freiheit und
brüderlichkeit zusammengehen
und ich glaube das ist irgendwie die die
uhr erfahrung sich zu fragen ob es nicht
auch freiheiten gebe die nicht im
kontrast zur brüderlichkeit stehen weil
sie eher ein füreinander bedeuten
als dann gegeneinander und da beginnt
die orientierung an einem anderen
freiheits modell das auch dem
liberalismus er entgegengesetzt ist
nämlich diese idee der sozialen freiheit
und soziale freiheit meint dass man die
die freiheit des einen zur bedingung der
einen freiheit macht ja das heißt dass
man sich in einem führender gemeinsam
für wirklich das muss man sich ja erst
mal auf der zunge zergehen lassen sie
preisen den sozialismus eigentlich auch
noch eine freiheitsbewegung und also
vielleicht verteidigen sie das noch
einmal erstmal wie die männer denken na
ja das sozialismus da geht darum dass
wir solidarisch sind auch dann wenn es
weh tut dann muss man halt mal seine
sachen daher geben man muss teilen man
verzicht üben zugunsten des wohles aller
und das ist noch mal was sie freiheit
beschränken
ja aber schauen sie das jetzt schon
unseren eher liberal getönten und zum
libal ismus gibt trägt eine freiheits
bürger voraus ja wo nach freiheit die
individuelle freiheit meine verfügung
über die realisierung meine eigenen
zwecke ist wenn wir diese forscher immer
abgeben das ist ein wichtiges gut
darüber können wir vielleicht anders
sprechen das ist ein sehr wichtiges gut
diese idee einer liberalen vorhalt einer
individuellen einer individuellen
freiheit aber dagegen muss man sich
glaube ich und haben die sozialisten
sehr früh damit begonnen dass es
zunächst mal alltäglich andere freiheits
erfahrung gibt die ist verdienen
gewissermaßen institutionalisiert zu
werden und das sind freiheiten im
miteinander und in der solidarität meint
dass das beispiel mit dem max immer
anhebt und das hat er wahrscheinlich von
seinem philosophischen lehre hegel
geerbt
ist das der liebe ja dass der frühe marx
redet immer wieder in seinen früh
schriften über die liebe als eine andere
form von freiheit weil in der liebe wir
unsere bedürfnisse wird die wir uns
lieben unser bedürfnis nur im
miteinander überhaupt verwirklichen
können und ist sehr seltsam wäre sich
die liebe als ein egoistisches
verhältnis zweier objekte vorzustellen
ja und in der liebe erfahre ich also so
stellt das hebelt schon ein bisschen
idealisierende romantisieren da in der
liebe erfahre ich meine entgrenzung als
gleichzeitig die verwirklichung des
anderen eine geglückte form der liebe
eine geglückte form der freundschaft hat
vielleicht auch etwas von diesem schub
der erfahrung einer eigentümlichen und
in unserer tradition nicht häufig
benannten form von freiheit ja dass
freiheit im miteinander und im
zueinander und also insofern glaube ich
gibt es in unserem alltag beispiel ich
würde auch sagen dass die demokratische
willensbildung wie wir sie kennen falsch
beschrieben wird wenn man sie als eine
bloß veranstaltung der realisierung
meine eigene zwecke verstehen
demokratischer bediensteten das
zusammentreffen der bürger und
bürgerinnen zum zwecke der
herausarbeitung eines gemeinsamen
willens ja das was hannah arendt als den
eigentlichen zweck der demokratischen
öffentlichkeit versteht ja der versuch
der schwierige komplizierte versuch sich
auf in form von debatten diskussionen
vielleicht auch protesten zu einigen auf
idealerweise dann gemeinsam wollen die
alte idee der demokratie wie sie rosso
schon entwickelt hat das zu beschreiben
als eine form der realisierung privater
freiheit ist glaube ich vollkommen
irreführend ja
es gibt ganz viele fragen die ich habe
bevor ich mit ihnen über die politik
spreche gegen die noch einmal zurück zu
lieben haben das jetzt so beschrieben
dass sie gesagt haben es gibt in der
liebe eine form von von freiheit wie das
eben hegel schon darstellt und marx
aufnimmt in dem sich zwei liebende
menschen einander so zuneigen dass sie
sich gemeinsam als frei erfahren wo
freie aus zuvor so gut ich würde nicht
viele die liebe so beschreiben dass sie
sagen würden
es sind zwei individuen sind frei und in
der liebe braucht man auf diese freiheit
nicht mehr man verliert vielleicht
freiheit aber sie ist auch gar nicht
mehr so wichtig wieder aber das
beschreibe ich glaube das beschreibt
nicht die eigentliche und und
tiefgreifende erfahrungen der liebe wie
sie auch in romanen oder in der poesie
beschrieben wird man gewinnt ja eine
neue form der freiheit eine gesteigerte
form der freiheit ich mach plötzlich die
erfahrung dass meine wünsche im anderen
resonanz finden im anderen
verwirklichung finden so dass ich den
anderen plötzlich nicht mehr als grenze
meiner wünsche die alltägliche erfahrung
vielleicht ja ich habe wünsche und die
stoßen auf hindernisse im anderen in
allen anderen menschen um uns herum ja
ich lerne mich als ein privates objekte
verstehen dass zwecksetzung ziele
wünsche hat die aber erst mal so
verstanden werden dass sie im anderen
eine grenze für mich muss immer checken
gewissermaßen ist der andere meiner
meine eigene münchen entgegen gesetzt
und die liebe wie die freundschaft
glaube ich bilden formen sozialer
erfahrung in denen das gerade nicht mehr
der fall ist sondern den den ich die
befreiende erfahrung macht dass meine
wünsche im anderen sich gewissermaßen
eine eine eigene tätige erfüllung sind
und das ist etwas anderes glaube ich als
die vorstellung
da kommen zwei subjekte zusammen die
ihre individuelle freiheit haben und die
dann
für sich vielleicht in einer beziehung
realisieren
sie haben recht und liebe ist so richtig
beschrieben
kann man das wirklich jetzt aus denen
sie haben auf die demokratie jetzt
hingewiesen auf ganze gemeinschaften an
sicher einfacher
wir haben dann vielleicht nicht mehr so
viel was wir teilen das natürlich ein
schönes bild das man in einer
politischen gemeinschaft auch sich auf
gemeinsame ziele verständigt aber sie
oft sehen wir das sehr unterschiedliche
interessen da sind
ich glaube sogar man muss da ganz
vorsichtig sein es gab immer ein zug
gerade so in den romantisch strömung des
sozialismus dieses dieses verständnis
von liebe sozial zu erweitern auf ganze
gruppen gemeinschaften das haben sie
auch manches muss häufig jakunin den
anarchistischen unterströmungen des
sozialismus
das halte ich für sehr problematisch für
falsch weil einer der erblasten des
sozialismus eine der wirklichen fehler
dürfen anfangen begeht ist sich die die
die großen differenzen zwischen den
unterschiedlichen lebens fairen unsere
modernen gesellschaften gar nicht im
rechten vor augen zu führen und sie die
klar zu machen dass sie jeweils
eigensinnigen ich würde mal sagen
gesetzmäßigkeiten oder normen
unterliegen ja und dann ist die
privatsphäre oder die sphäre solch ein
team beziehungen wie sie freundschaft
und liebe darstellen etwas ganz anderes
als etwa die politische sphäre der
gemeinsamen willensbildung oder noch
wieder etwas anders als die ökonomische
wäre
interessanterweise aber lassen sich
glaube ich wenn man recht tut diese
unterschiedlichen sphären mit hilfe des
selben modells von freiheit beschreiben
ja sie dürfen nur nicht so verstanden
werden dass sie alle als liebes
gemeinschaften beschrieb werde das war
entsetzlich der frühe hegel hat diesen
schritt manchmal getan auch marx neigt
manchmal dazu an vielen stellen bevor er
dann zum ökonom wird zum kritik der
politischen ökonomie wird
nein mein hinweis auf die politische
willensbildung oder demokratischen
meinungsbildung sollte meinen hier
findet in einer anderen form
eine ähnliche gestalt von freiheit ihre
nieren ihren ausdruck nämlich der dass
wir uns ergänzen
ja es ist ja so dass irgendwie der john
juli der amerikanische philosoph hat das
so wunderschön geschrieben nehmen wir
unter demokratie den gang zur wahlurne
verstehen dann ist es ein privat eine
die realisierung einer privaten freiheit
wären wir bei darunter verstehen dass
wir wechselseitig einander zuhören und
wechselseitig eigentlich uns in unserer
meinung überprüfen wollen um zu einem
besseren ergebnis in der bestimmung des
gemeinwohls zu kommen
dann hat es viel mehr etwas von einem
füreinander und die die demokratie
freiheit lässt sich dann eben nicht
beschreiben als bloß die realisierung
dieses individuelle nacktes sondern ist
angewiesen auf austausch füreinander
miteinander und insofern stellt auch sie
denkt ich meine form eine andere form
von freiheit als die die zunächst mal
die liberalen folgen lassen sie uns um
das vielleicht noch ein bisschen
plastischer werden zu lassen kann man
die seite wechseln und was sagen denn
die liberalen dazu weil sie ja
tatsächlich versuchen den sozialismus
auch auf eine gegenbewegung eben nicht
zum kapitalismus sondern zum
liberalismus oder sogar ein stiefkind
des goldes machen ich will ich will die
beiden bewegung gar nicht so weit
auseinander
ein sozialismus der nicht die liberale
lehre mit gelernt hat und sich nicht
mehr auch als dem liberalismus
verpflichtet versteht stellt eine
problematisch da werden sie schon fast
sozialdemokratische oder so da kommen
wir dann später noch darauf aber schauen
wir uns dem liberalismus an wenn man so
guckt im politischen denken oder in der
in der politischen philosophie in 20
aber wahrscheinlich schon als der
wichtigste politische philosoph des
liberalismus den liberalen gedanken
weiter entwickelt hat und wir haben auf
sf kultur gegenwärtig unter dem titel
philosoph fix verschiedene gedanken
experimenten mit von philosophen die man
in animierten kurzfilmen sich auch auf
unserer website an stören und darunter
ist auch das gedanken
von john roos der schleier des
nichtwissens lassen sie uns das macht
das gut und habe die reichsten schweizer
nur ein prozent der bevölkerung besitzen
knapp die hälfte des vermögens aller
schweizer zusammen die chance dass ein
akademiker kind eine hochschule besucht
ist in der schweiz 1,5 mal höher als die
eines nichtakademiker kindes frauen
verdienen in der schweiz für den
gleichen job im schnitt 20 prozent
weniger als männer
ist das gerecht wie müsste eine welt
beschaffen sein in der echte
gerechtigkeit herrscht stell dir vor du
kannst gemeinsam mit anderen festlegen
wie eine gerechte gesellschaft
auszusehen hat welche güter verteilt wer
wie wer hat welche rechte wer kriegt den
spitzen job.de nur eine haben kann
was ist ein gerechter lohn
hier diskutiert und diskutiert und
entwirft die gerechte welt damit eure
entscheide nicht parteiisch ausfallen
und ihr nicht einen staat zu euren
gunsten entwerft wird euch ein schleier
des nichtwissens umgebunden
hinter dem schleier wisst ihr nicht
werde ich in dieser welt eine frau sein
oder ein mann werde ich in einer
wohlsituierten akademikerfamilie
aufwachsen oder als kind einer
mittellosen migrantenfamilie lebe ich in
der stadt oder auf dem land ohne fordern
mit kindern bin ich sportlich oder eher
nicht religiös oder atheistisch keine
ahnung
ihr macht die spielregeln ist aber nicht
an welcher position er später spielen
werdet in diesem urzustand werdet ihr
euch auf wenige prinzipien einigen die
eine gerechte gesellschaft ausmachen
das meint john rawls der erfinder dieses
gedankenexperiment er glaubt ihr
entscheidet euch hinter dem schleier des
nichtwissens für eine gesellschaft in
der es den am schlechtesten gestellten
möglichst gut geht denn ihr könntet ja
in dieser position sein
dieses sogenannte differenz prinzip
behauptet selbst ungleichheiten können
gerecht sein nämlich dann wenn sie
denjenigen zugute kommen die am
wenigsten haben
das heißt der ceo eine grossbank darf
sich ohne schlechtes gewissen einen
exorbitanten lohn auszahlen wenn auch
der angestellte am bankschalter mehr
verdient
gegen ungleichheit kann man nichts sagen
solange alle davon profitieren
stimmt das was ist gerecht hatte ihnen
welche defizite reicht das nicht
dazu wächst man muss ich sagen das war
wunderbar dargestellt ja und dieser
dieser gedanke über gerechtigkeit
prinzipien derart nachzudenken dass wir
uns fragen welche prinzipien würden wir
wählen er hätten wir einen solchen
steuer des nichtwissens ist ein genialer
gedanke ja der übersetzung von
bestimmten kantischen ideen ist denke
ich er hat diese idee dass wir neutral
darüber befinden müssen was gerecht ist
für die aber diese inhalte form gefunden
hat die jesus schön mit dem tatsächlich
steuer dann auch symbolisiert wird die
hat defizite denke ich auch wenn sich
holz das sollte man sie auch klarmachen
gerade in seinen späten schriften sehr
sozialdemokratisch ein bisschen zu
sozialistischen gedanken angenähert hat
auch hier ist ja ein
sozialdemokratischer funke durchaus
enthalten ja das ist nicht der
marktliberalismus das ist nun das ist
sogar mehr als der politische
liberalismus den wir kennen ja der im
wesentlichen sich einsetzt für die
bedingungen politischer freiheit
bürgerrechte und ähnliches sondern wir
haben es bei rot schon zu tun mit einem
auch und ökonomische besorgten überall
ismus um ökonomische gerechtigkeit
besorgten ihr wollt ist muss das ist
eine neuartigkeit in der geschichte des
journalismus man muss sich die
sonderstellung rolls in dieser hinsicht
immer klar machen
ja der ist das wollen manche seiner
schüler und schülerinnen vielleicht gar
nicht so sehr war haben in dem sinne
schon eine ein sozialistischer veteran
im feld des liberalismus
naja sagen wir ja aber ich glaube das
kann man auch sehen
und gerade wenn man übrigens die späten
schriften in denen das immer deutlicher
werden
wenn er sich direkt auseinandersetzt
irgendwie mit der frage welche
institutionen eigentlich in der
ökonomischen sphäre angebracht werden so
dass diese gerechtigkeit effekte erzeugt
werden
ich glaube es reicht deswegen nicht hin
weil es doch immer vom einzelnen aus die
gerechtigkeit zu konzipieren versucht
und daher nicht in den blick recht dass
möglicherweise auch bestimmte
institutionen der des füreinander und
gemeinsam der gemeinsamkeit
ein wesentliches anliegen soziale
gerechtigkeit sein müsste ja zum
beispiel auch die familie immer in einer
sozial randständigen funktion beim auf
ja überhaupt intime beziehung privat
beziehung spielen deswegen keine rolle
weil wir hinter diesem steuer des
nichtwissens eben auch nicht wissen
können in welchen sozialen institutionen
wir wirklich uns dann frei fühlen ja das
können wir alles nicht wissen und
insofern würde ich sagen der schleier
des nichtwissens ist viel zu starke zu
ja wir wissen eigentlich zu wenig um
tatsächlich dabei befinden zu können was
von heute aus gesehen unter unserer
gegenwärtigen bedingungen soziale
gerechtigkeit sein sollte weil wir jetzt
zu wenig an erfahrung darüber haben
welche institutionen und welche sozialen
sphären eigentlich in einem nicht
individualistischen sinn gerechtigkeit
produzieren sind sie würden sagen das
bin was er hat diese menschen die sich
darin den den schleier umbinden
wir sind sozusagen zu nackt ja die
müssen auch als beziehungs wesen
dargestellt sein beispiel was hätte das
denn für auswirkungen was würden sie
sagen dass differenz prinzip wird hier
ja dargestellt also ungleichheiten sind
dann gerechtfertigt wenn sie auch den
schlechter gestellten schlechtes
gestalten helfen wenn sie sie voran
bringen was würden sie denn sagen was
würde das verändern bezüglich dass die
vereins prinzips na ja man könnte zum
beispiel sagen dass überhaupt keine
rolle bei rolls die frage spielt welche
arten von arbeiten wir wie organisieren
die frage nach sinnvollen arbeiten sind
eigentlich alle arbeiten gleichermaßen
bestimmten gruppen von menschen zumutbar
es spielt auch keine rolle die frage
welche arten von beziehungen wir heute
wollen können ja das sind also fragen
die die aus dem spektrum von
gerechtigkeit fangen herausfallen müssen
glaube ich weil eben gibt weil erstens
wir mit dieser steuer des nichtwissens
einfach zu wenig über uns wissen ja wir
haben eben bedürfnisse oder wir haben
inzwischen kulturell entwickelte
bedürfnisse auch von denen haben wir da
weniger ahnung hinter diesem schleier
des nichtwissens zudem stellen sich
unsere bestimmte fragen gar nicht die er
so dem bereich des sozialen umgangs
untereinander berühren weil wir weil wir
die frage hinter diesem streit ist nicht
wissen zu stellen dass wir uns immer
fragen wie würde ich als dies neutral
gewesen mich am besten stellen und dann
komme ich natürlich darauf zu sagen und
das ist wie gesagt keine falsche idee
ich stelle mich dann gut wenn ich weiß
dass die erlaubte ungleichheit mir auch
noch in einer schlechten situation
zugute kommen das ist im grunde genommen
darüber gibt es eine riesige diskussion
natürlich wenn sie sich vorstellen
können oder wie wir wissen dass enthält
übrigens schon ein bestimmtes bildes
markt ist wie man sich sehr deutlich
macht auch hier sehr schön dargestellt
wurde es besagt nämlich dass anreize
nämlich ökonomische anreize zum beispiel
managergehälter in einer bestimmten höhe
dann gerechtfertigt sind wenn sie den
schlechtes gestellten zugute konstruiert
das ja auch extrem oft dass man seine
firma braucht halt den besten manager
wenn man richtig und graviert sozusagen
für alle mehr dabei herauskommt wenn in
den allerbesten holt mit dem aller
thorsten gehört aber das erlauben sie
nicht glauben sie dass ein tierisch
nicht oder finden sie das einfach sein
erstens glaube ich das empirisch nicht
unbedingt leute sind auch anders
motiviert ja
gerade interessante komplizierte
arbeiten zu übernehmen nicht nur nicht
nur durch geld anreize sondern
möglicherweise auch durch die atmosphäre
im betrieb durch bestimmte soziale
voraussetzungen in ihrem unternehmen
möglicherweise im übrigen auch durch die
orte an die sie kommen ja also die die
forschung dass das alles über
ökonomische anreize funktioniert halte
ich schon für die fixierung auf eine
bestimmte bild des kapitalistischen
marktes und das hat es am ende auch
selber gesehen glaube ich und mit
antworten die die form der institution
auf die hier der ganze blick gerichtet
wird die selber wird nicht hinterfragt
welche art von marc topp man auch andere
märkte ob man die märkte anders
etablieren kann wo man überhaupt märkte
zu lassen möchte all diese riesigen
fragen die sich mit bezug auf die
marktwirtschaft oder die kapitalistische
marktwirtschaft stellen werden irgendwie
ausgeblendet ja weil es kein sensorium
hinter dem schleier des nichtwissens
dafür gibt welche formen die
institutionen besetzen sollen wenn wir
zurückgehen zu ihrem vorschlag dann
kriege ich immer ein bisschen den
eindruck wenn ich ihn jetzt zu hören sie
sagen der wahrheit schaut er ist auch
motiviert vielleicht tun genau kaum
motiviert seien dadurch aber auch wenn
man ihr buch liest kriege ich ein
bisschen den eindruck sie zeichnen die
menschen vielleicht besser aus sie sind
und dann frage ich mich ist es nicht so
dass man lange zeit den eindruck hatte
eigentlich ist der sozialismus etwas für
schwache und der liberalismus ist etwas
für die starken und sie zeichnen es
gerade umgekehrt eigentlich müssen wir
ganz schön stark sein und auch sagen wir
mal sehr gute menschen um sozialistisch
agieren zu können und ehre
der liberalismus ist etwas für schwache
ist das so ich hoffe nicht also was ich
nicht hoffe ist dass ich von einer zu
von einem zu optimistischen menschen wie
das geht
das wird ja häufig vielleicht im
sozialismus vorgeworfen vielleicht
meinte dass auch zetsche
in seinem in seiner polemischen
bemerkung über den 40-jährigen der
verstand genug hat um nicht mehr
sozialist zu sein
nein ich glaube nicht man muss von
einer guten natur des menschen ausgehen
auf jeden fall hoffe ich nicht dass der
sozialismus darauf angewiesen ist weil
ich nicht weiß ob es sich so verhält ja
das heißt in hinblick auf die frage ob
wir nun von natur aus gut oder schlecht
sind habe ich keine antwort bereit
können wir gar keine bereit haben glaube
ich wir müssen uns nur deutlich der
erfahrung aus setzen dass sich die
bereitschaft zur solidarität mit
historischen erfahrungen auch ständig
ändern ja dass das keine fixe größe ist
im augenblick sind wir sehr daran
gewöhnt glaube ich anzunehmen die
menschen seien private egoisten das
hängt natürlich auch mit unserer
gegenwärtigen kultur zusammen der stadt
die das fördert oder gefördert hat
vielleicht findet ja ein um längen statt
man muss sich nur klar man hat das
geschieht ganz leicht wenn man so
einfach sich wirtschaftsgeschichte oder
sozial geschichten anschaut dass das
etwa in den 50er und 60er jahren ganz
anders war ja der waren auch die reichen
sage ich mal ein bisschen abkürzen tja
viel stärker von sozialen impulsen
bewegt und die bereitschaft zu teilen
und damit solidarische grund gefühle und
effekte waren viel weiter vertreten und
entwickelt ich glaube nicht dass es eine
fixe natur geht ich glaube dass diese
natur enorm abhängig ist von
historischen zeitumständen von vom
kulturellen bildern auch von den
institutionen in dem wir geprägt sind
und da lässt sich eben leichte
beobachtung machen dass die bereitschaft
hohe steuern zu zahlen etwa in den 60er
50er und 60er jahren des letzten
jahrhunderts enorm hoch jetzt haben sie
aber selber auch gemeinschaft kann und
darf man nicht verordnen gemeinschaft
muss sich ergeben also solidarität kann
nicht von oben aufs neue dort sind wir
tatsächlich wie den kommunismus wie soll
die sich denn ergeben wie kann man das
vielleicht doch fördern oder anschubsen
heute spricht man so einen abschuss
liberalismus sie kommen wenn die leute
dahin schubsen
ich glaube der sozialismus hatte als
eine der großen aufgaben überhaupt
wieder eine wahrnehmung zu schaffen
für den wert dieser sozialen freiheiten
ich glaube das ist eine ganz große
aufgabe weil unsere kultur heute so
beschaffen ist dass sie eher die
ausblendet und selbst damit beginnt
bestimmte institutionen soziale freiheit
im sinne nur noch der privat
egoistischen feier zu deuten
familie freundschaften aber auch der
markt man muss sich ja klar machen
der markt wurde innerhalb der sozial das
was man mal soziale marktwirtschaft und
eine sozialdemokratische idee viel
stärker als eine institution der
koordinierung von interessen verstanden
aber nicht des anreizes von egoistischen
motiven das heißt selbst das bild des
marktes wandelt sich immer mit der zeit
und ich glaube der sozialismus oder
einer der aufgaben des sozialismus im
augenblick wo ja keine großen
bereitschaften da sind ja für eine
sozialistische zukunft zu kämpfen ist es
ein sensorium zu schaffen für die ideen
sozialer freiheit die den sozialismus
eigentlich immer die schubkraft gegeben
haben und ihn im übrigen zu einer
freiheitsbewegung das haben sie von mir
schon gesagt gemacht haben und gerade
nicht zu einer bewegung nur der
gleichheit ich glaube es ist ein grund
mehr schönes zu sagen der sozialismus
kämpft einfach mit allen mitteln für die
durchsetzung von gleichheit
ich glaube er kämpft für soziale
freiheiten die kern erfahrung war die
der kooperation ja das machte die die
ursprungs erfahrung aus oder die liebe
bei marx aber früher auch die
kooperation dass das freiwillige
miteinander arbeiten
der etwa der handwerker gemeinschaft ja
das waren so ideale vorbilder und dafür
wieder ein sensoren zu schaffen scheint
mir ein grundanliegen gerade in unseren
gegenwärtigen zeiten nicht interessiert
hat immer interessiert auch ihr
interesse für bob dylan
sie haben bob dylan immer geschätzt sie
haben sogar 2006 einen kongress
organisiert über bob dylan und
philosophie und bob dylan steht für sie
denn ihren aufsatz in diesen bahnen lief
eigentlich genau wie die idee dass der
mensch immer unterschiedliche formen von
freiheit in sich hat unterschiedliche
momente er hat einerseits dieses
freiheitspartei ich möchte mich gerne
verwirklichen und andererseits dieses
gefühl von ich möchte mich auch
verlieben ich möchte mich sorgen ich
möchte mich fallen lassen und eben in
dieser sozialen freiheit nicht
aufgehoben fühlen sie sagen in einem
lied von boddien kommt was besonders
vornehmlich in it's not targets
[Musik]
uns gehen
wir merken
[Musik]
sk
die luft
[Musik]
ich meine so ein alter ein sehr schönes
nicht sie haben gerade gesagt ein altes
lied ja ich meine der der die zentrale
strophe ich verstehe das immer so das
ist auch ein abschiedslied ist es ist
das lied eines alten mannes er wird
diese mir glaube ich 75 und der nochmals
revue passieren lässt was eigentlich
wovon man eigentlich sich so ganz
allmählich zu verabschieden beginnt und
tatsächlich bin ich der überzeugung die
mögen andere andere mögen anders
verstehen sie wissen dass es da
millionen von deutschland gibt ja und
anhängern dass er immer aus trägt die
die komplexität unserer
unterschiedlichen freiheits vorstellung
und auch die schwere versöhnlichkeit ja
sie haben das schon erwähnt es gibt
natürlich diese auch faszinierende idee
der der freiheit als befreiung von etwas
ja ich lass alles hinter mir mein
elternhaus ja die bindung an diese an
dieses dorf an diese stadt und setz mich
frei das ist sicherlich ein ein
bewunderungswürdig ehrenwertes frites
motiv glaube ich und wir dürfen uns auch
eine kultur der zukunft eine freie
kultur der zukunft nicht ohne dieses
motiv vorstellen
das heißt auch in einer anderen
gesellschaft von wenn man da überhaupt
so abstrakt von reden möchte bedarf es
immer dieser dieser freiräume tigers
erlauben und ich glaube der die
institution die diese art von freiheit
erlaubt ist glaube ich das recht dass
das individuelle recht dass uns zukommt
uns von bindungen zu lösen und
tatsächlich unsere eigenen wege
einzuschlagen ohne dass uns jemand fragt
warum
dem steht aber gegenüber was eigentlich
die liberale freiheit das ist die es ist
ja eine facette der über einheit die
andere ist sehr stark mit dem markt
verbuchen
vielleicht anders zu verstehen
sicherlich eine 1 ein impuls der die
wahlfreiheit
du musst dir muss gesichert sein dass du
von bindungen zumutungen und
verpflichtungen die in deinem umfeld
bestehen dich freisetzen das ist
sicherlich bewahrenswert auch vom
liberalismus dem steht gegenüber in den
liedern von denen über den wir gerade
sprechen immer diese ganz andere
freiheits vorstellung die er so in den
usa zum beispiel kommunizieren gerade
hat ja ich bin frei eigentlich erst in
der gemeinschaft sich wechselseitig bei
der verwirklichung helfender mitglieder
oder subjekte ja dafür gibt es
fantastische bilder in amerikanischen
tradition ja die die die
dorfgemeinschaft sich gemeinsam für
wirklich dass von jedem als freund als
zu wirksam trotzdem seien sie hat
eigentlich in amerika keine wirkliche
sozialistische tradition das ist ich
meine da dabei könnte man lange reden in
die usa ist irgendwie in der hinsicht
ungetrübt das haben das eine
interessante kultur er weil sie zwei
sehr entgegengesetzte freiheits
vorstellungen in ihrer tradition immer
schon besetzen hat diese diese sehr
individualistisch über die wir
gesprochen haben ja die auch stark
sicherlich mit der der
entstehungsgeschichte der usa
zusammenhängen und die kommunität die
viel stärker in die subjektive die etwa
in dem von mir hoch geschätzten auch am
anfang zitierte wort widmen immer
gefeiert werden ja wo freiheit
gemeinschaft ist ja und ich glaube der
dänen trägt diese unterschiedlichen
komponenten in sande dann häufig so aus
dass er uns erfahren lässt wie schwer
sie vereinbar sind und dass wir aber an
allen eine gewisse bindung haben ja wir
können wir sind in der hinsicht falsch
verstanden wenn wir uns nur in einer
hinsicht als frei oder nur an einer
frites vorstellung gebunden
der sozialismus lenkt eben die
aufmerksamkeit stehen
auf diese soziale form der freiheit
kommen wir zum schluss noch mal auf ihr
buch zurück sie betonen ja sehr dass sie
kein politisches programm vorlegen und
dass sie selber nicht einmal sicher sind
ob sich der sozialismus wieder
realisieren lässt sondern es ist eine
art ein plädoyer für ein experiment ein
ausprobieren der idee des sozialismus
schauen was könnte man daraus nehmen und
bis heute wieder was von mir irgendwo zu
entzünden wenn sie jetzt aber politiker
wären herr horn etwas werden sie aus dem
buch rauspicken und sagen was würde ich
als erstes jetzt noch ändern wollen oder
das würde ich gerne aus idee wirklich
ausprobieren wollen
also ich glaube die das feld an dass man
zuallererst dran muss ist tatsächlich
die wirtschaft und ich würde ich denke
mit vielen da beginne ich würde ehrlich
gesagt wenn ich kulturpolitiker wer oder
wissenschaftspolitiker würde ich als
erstes gehen an die renovierung unserer
wirtschaftswissenschaftlichen fakultäten
und das heißt ich würde dafür sorge
tragen dass die wirtschaftslandschaft
anders gelehrt und wieder viel stärker
historisch sich orientiert dass die
prämissen die dort für
selbstverständlich gehalten werden es
sind alles prämissen des freimarktes
erst mal in ihrer bedeutung wieder
reflektiert werden dass auch dort
nachgedacht wird über mögliche
alternativen zu unserer gegenwärtigen
wirtschaft also mit anderen worten ich
würde an der ausbildung einsetzen und
mich fragen ob nicht ein baustein der
des umstands dass wir so fixiert sind
auf genau diese gestalt des
kapitalistischen marktes nicht zu finden
ist
in dem zustand unserer
wirtschaftswissenschaften das werden die
kollegen mir wahrscheinlich übernehmen
oder kollegin der
wirtschaftswissenschaftlichen fakultäten
obwohl die klagen selbst dort lauter
werden von denen die eine ausbildung
sind und von denen die dort lehren
das ist eine so verein seite und ihre
eigenen soziales einen sozialen ort
nicht mehr bewusste wissenschaft dass
ich dort beginnen würde
und dann natürlich würde ich
zurückkehren zu den ex
momenten mit denen im sozialismus immer
schon operiert worden ist natürlich
sollte man sich gedanken machen über
stärker form der mitbestimmung ja man
sollte darüber sich gedanken machen wie
die krassen unterschied von arm und
reich
durch umbauten im wirtschaftssystem
verändert werden können wie negative
effekte des wirtschaftssystems auf
unsere umwelt verhindert werden können
und so weiter also in der reiche der
brennpunkt ein breit
ich danke ihnen sehr für dieses gespräch
damit begonnen und nach ihnen danke ich
für sie interesse nächste woche
unterzieht mein kollege stephan klappt
gut die idee des sozialismus einem
praxistest
er spricht mit griechenlands ehemaligen
finanzminister yannis warum marquis der
mit marx im gepäck die mächtigen der eu
von ihrem spardiktat abbringen wollte
und jetzt gleich zeigen wir ihnen in der
sternstunde kunst ein filmporträt über
alberto giacometti der wie kein anderer
aus pickelharte meisen eine zeit der
welt des filigranen schuf ich wünsche
ihnen einen schönen sonntag
[Musik]